hello everyone and welcome to a brand
new python tutorial series
so in this series i'm going to be
teaching you the basics and fundamentals
of the python programming language and
we're going to immediately be applying
those into our own project slash game
so the idea behind this series is that
not only do i want to teach you these
concepts
but i want us to actually apply them
into a project so we can see where
they're used
and how we use them so at the end of
this series you will have a complete
finished game that you will be able to
show off
and the way that we're going to be
making this game makes it really
extendable and flexible so you can add
your own stuff and really customize it
as we go through so before i say
anything else let me just note that this
tutorial series is really for complete
beginners
this is for people looking to get up and
running in python as fast as possible
and in these next three videos we're
going to be learning a bunch of
different skills and syntax and then by
the end
we're going to have that complete
project so let me show you an example of
what this project could look like
keep in mind this is just like kind of a
smaller version of what it might be
this is very flexible and we might make
it a little bit different as we go
through
so let me run this and the type of
project that we're really making here is
a choose your own adventure game
now in my opinion this is one of the
best projects you can work on as a
beginner
because of how flexible it really is so
let me just show you what it is and then
you guys should get an idea pretty
quickly of why this is a great project
to work on
so you can see it says welcome to my
first game what is your name i'm going
to put tim
what is your age let's put 19 and says
you are old enough to play do you want
to play
let's type yes it says you are starting
with 10 health alright
let's play first choice left or right
let's decide to go left
you can see that what's kind of
happening here is these first steps
we're just setting up in the game
but now it's going to give me a bunch of
decisions to make and based on what i
choose at previous steps
it'll give me different decisions so i
decide to go left here
it says nice you follow the path and
reach a lake you swim across or go
around
what do we think do we go across or go
around let's go across
so i go across it says you managed to
get across but you were bit by a fish
and lost five health
you notice a house in a river which do
you go to the river or the house so
let's decide to go to the river
and let's see you fell in the river and
you lost so hopefully that gives you an
idea of how this works let me run it one
more time and i'll show you
that there's different options that will
pop up based on where you decide to go
so tim 19 yes you're starting with 10
health let's play if i decide to go
right
notice that immediately i just lose
right so there's all
these different paths and kind of
decision trees and branches that we can
go down
and it makes this game really cool
because it's pretty simple to create
obviously for beginners that's what
we're going to be doing
but it's also really cool and really
flexible and you can kind of make
whatever you want out of it
so with that being said we need to get
our coding environment set up here
fortunately for us we're actually going
to be using a platform called replit
so it's replit so repl it
this is an online browser-based coding
environment and i'm just going to walk
us through how we can actually set this
environment up
and get started right away without
having to download or install any
software
so as i mentioned we're going to be
using an online coding platform called
replit so it's spelt repl it
that is the website url i will link that
in the description as well
but this is a free browser-based coding
environment so what that means is that
the only prerequisite for this series
is that you have a browser and you have
internet connection
so to get started you need to go to this
link and obviously sign up if you don't
have an account
or log in so i'm going to log in but
when you sign up
it's going to ask you to input your
favorite programming language
i would recommend you just select python
it doesn't matter but that's just
something that you will have to go
through to get this set up
so i'm going to go here to new rapple
and i'm going to select python
and give this a name now the name that
i'm going to give mine is first game
feel free to name yours whatever you'd
like and then just notice that
this will be a public rebel which means
it'll show up on your profile and
everyone can see it
if you want to go for private rebels
that is kind of a premium feature but
i wouldn't worry about that we're not
making anything that we care if someone
steals
so let's go create repple and let's boot
up into our first environment
all right so the first important thing
that we need to understand is how we can
actually
print things and get things to show up
in the console
so before remember how when i ran the
code we would see some kind of output
right it said like do you want to play
the game or it would
tell us some kind of message so how do
we actually go ahead and do that
well the first command we're going to
learn in python is known as print
so all of the things i'm about to show
you are pretty much called syntax
syntax is really like the grammar of a
programming language it's like where
does the period go
where do we have parentheses it's just
the structure the way that we write the
code and if you hear me
use the word syntax that's what that
means but the syntax to print something
out
in python is really simple we just put
print
we put an open parenthesis and a closed
parenthesis
and then inside of the print statement
we put a set of single
or double quotation marks and inside of
these quotation marks whatever we want
to print to the screen
so you can think of it as like we're
printing a quote right if you wanted to
say that although this is going to be
referred to as something else that i'll
talk about in a second
and whatever is inside of these
quotation marks that text will just show
up in the console
so if i say hello world the classic
first program
then let's run and we get hello world
popping up in the console
so this is the easiest way to print
something out there's a bunch of other
ways we can use this statement but again
it's just print
open parentheses and then you need these
these double quotation marks or single
quotation marks doesn't matter which one
but make sure the set is obviously the
same so you don't go like
single quotation mark double quotation
mark that won't work and then whatever
inside of here that you want to print
out
so let's apply this now immediately into
our project like i said
the first thing we want to do in our
choose your own adventure game is
probably introduce the user or whoever
is playing
to the game right so what i'm going to
say is
welcome oops if i could type welcome
to my first game
now you guys can obviously put whatever
you want inside of here i'm just going
to say welcome to my first game
maybe you want to be more creative and
put the name of your game although we
might
not even know what that is yet but don't
worry we can always go back and change
that
all right so print welcome to my first
game great so that is the print
now what i need to talk about is
variables and data types
now this is a really important concept
now this is going to be a little bit
more theoretical it's hard to apply this
but we definitely need to understand
this so inside of python we kind of have
four main types of information or data
so in our programming languages we have
data right that's
information that we're maybe going to
store that we're going to pass around
that we're going to manipulate
if you think of an application where
we're just counting say we're just
counting up
well we're going to have to have some
notion of like what the counts at right
that would be
an example of data that we're going to
store in our program there's lots of
examples of this
but these data this data that we have
has different data types
and there's kind of four main ones that
we need to cover so the first one is
string
the second one is int then we have float
and then we have
bull now a string which is represented
by str i'll actually just type out
string here so you can see it fully
is anything wrapped inside of double
quotation marks
or single quotation marks so like hello
is an example of a string
hi is an example of a string 9 89 is an
example of a string anything that's
inside of double or single quotation
marks is a string
and strings are just a collection of
characters they're just
text right and usually we're going to
use strings just to print stuff
out to the console um there's a bunch of
other use cases of them of course but
for now
that's what we can kind of think of as
strings next we have ins
now ins are any whole number so just the
number they're not wrapped in quotation
marks or anything like that
just any whole number it could be
negative as well that's totally fine it
could be a really big number
any whole number that does not have any
decimal points is an int otherwise known
as an integer
so that kind of follows our
understanding for math so hopefully that
one makes sense
next we have float now a float is any
number that has a floating decimal point
so if i have something like 6.0 that's a
float because we have a decimal point
and then something after
we have a number like 7.5 that's a float
negative 9.8 that's a float and
negative 100.0 again if float so even if
it's a dot o which
technically is still a whole number
right because 100.0 is a whole number
if it has this decimal point anywhere
it's considered a float
and lastly we have a boolean a boolean
is one of two values
true or false so these two exact things
that i typed
nothing different about them so the
capital t and the capital f is very
important
if you see one of these two things and
you can see they're kind of highlighting
in blue telling us their fancy uh
fancy thing in the language and those
are booleans
so i'll leave this and what i'm gonna
call a comment which is actually
interesting to show you guys so if i do
three quotation marks
and then i do another three quotation
marks like this this is actually what
represents a comment or a multi-line
comment inside of python
this isn't super important to understand
but what this means is that whatever i
wrap
inside of these triple quotation marks
and i can put these anywhere i want
this will just be ignored by my program
so right now we're going to print this
right
and that's going to work fine but if i
were to wrap this inside of triple
quotation marks
we can see it kind of gets commented out
and now that means our program is just
going to ignore whatever is inside of
these sets of triple quotation marks
so if i run my program i no longer am
printing that out
and there's actually another way to make
a comment as well and that's to use a
pound sign
and what this does is simply comment at
one line so it just comments out
whatever comes
after it on the line this sometimes is
useful if you just want to comment at
one line
not a whole block of code like i've done
here so i'll leave this down a little
bit at the bottom of the screen
and now we'll actually start writing a
bit more code so
there we go we understand data types now
we need to talk about variables
so variables are essentially a way of
storing data
now you can think of a variable like in
math right where we had like x
equals 5 x equals 7. that's a really
similar way that they work here in
programming
and to make a variable just show you a
few examples it's quite easy
you simply pick a name for your variable
in this case let's say
x you put an equals sign and on the
right hand side you put some
data type or you assign it equal to
another variable
or some other things that we'll talk
about later but essentially you put
something on the right hand side that
you want to be stored in the variable
so in this case maybe i want my variable
x to store an int
which is uh the value 5. awesome there
we go that's all i need to do to make a
variable x that stores the value 5.
now if i actually go ahead and write
another print statement here
which is totally valid we can write as
many print statements as we want
what's going to happen now is we're
going to print welcome to my first game
we're going to read the next line
because we do read code top to bottom
most times other than certain
circumstances but you can think that
when we execute the program we read from
the top
so left to right top to bottom that's
just the way it works so then we
we do this we set x equal to 5 and now
what i'm going to do is actually print
x now notice that i didn't surround x in
quotation marks
the reason i didn't surround it in
quotation marks is because it's a
variable so a variable is actually
something that i can print
totally fine right inside of the print
statement because i'm not trying to
print out the letter
x i'm trying to print out whatever the
value is that's stored in the variable x
so in this case i'm going to print out 5
because x equals 5. so if i run this
let's have a look
welcome to my first game five awesome
there we go we now kind of understand
variables
so of course i can store other things in
variables too i could store the value
true right this would be considered a
boolean or a bool
let's have a look at this now so now we
print out true and that's kind of the
basics on variables they can store
things
so you set a variable name equal to
something there's a few rules with our
variables the first has to do with their
naming
so when we create a variable all we kind
of have to do is just type something out
and set it equal to something else
but the thing that we type out or the
variable name has to follow these rules
it can only contain lowercase and
uppercase letters
underscores and numbers so it cannot
contain any special characters other
than an underscore
and it cannot start with a number so
something like hello one
is totally valid hello one equals nine
awesome hello one underscore
totally valid but as soon as i go one
hello
note you can see we're getting this red
squiggly line not allowed we cannot
start a variable with a number
but i can go ahead and do something like
that that's fine i can put a number in
between
just follow those rules and typically
you don't really use numbers in your
variable names you're just going to use
some text maybe uppercase and lowercase
letters
and in python if you want to do a space
because there's no spaces allowed in
variable names
just use an underscore so something like
hello underscore world
this is the convention for making
variables you separate anything that's
kind of two words using an underscore
so let's say hello equals nine right and
then we could print out hello and we'd
get the value nine
now of course we can make a lot of other
variables too we can say the variable
yes
equals and maybe it's equal to the
string hello
i can actually do something crazy and
say hello equals yes
now what that's saying is that hello
this variable hello
is equal to whatever is stored in the
variable yes so in this case hello will
be equal to hello
funny right but that's how that will
work so we can assign variables to other
variables
we can do something like hello equals
hello plus nine totally fine and in fact
what i'm going to do now
excuse me is i'm going to try to
actually show you how we can ask the
user for some input
and store what they type in in a
variable so now we're on to the next
part which is getting user input so to
get user input what that means is that
in the console here we're going to let
the user type something in
because right now if i run this you see
that it says welcome to my first game
and then the program kind of just ends
after that
ideally i would like to ask the user
what their name is and store that in a
variable
so let's go ahead and do that i'll just
print it out and then i'll talk about
how this actually works so i'm going to
make a variable called
name the reason i've called it name is
because it's going to store my user's
name and usually we want to name our
variables something that are meaningful
and i've set that equal to input and
inside of this here i'm going to put a
string that is the question i want to
ask the user
so what is your name question mark
now notice i did a little space at the
end try to think of why i would have
done this space in just a second but
just keep in mind i did do this space
just remember that so now what i'm going
to show you is what happens when i run
this program so let me move this over
here
let's zoom in welcome to my first game
what is your name
let me type tim alright so i typed him
and notice that here the cursor
is going and i can type stuff right into
the console that's because i used this
input key so what this says if i have
input
and then i put what's known as a prompt
inside of here that whenever we
read this line of codes when our program
actually reads this it will say okay
print this out and then wait for the
user to hit
enter so let them type something
whenever after we print this out so on
the same line as what is your name and
then as soon as they hit
enter we're actually going to take
whatever they typed and we're going to
store it in the variable name
so if i type tim like that what actually
ends up happening and i'll have to zoom
back out here
is that the variable name is going to be
equal to tim
because i typed tim and then if i type
joe
the variable name is going to be equal
to joe because i typed joe
so to prove that to you let me print out
name because we can print out variables
right so this variable should equal the
name we typed in
and then let's just print it out so
let's have a look what is your name
tim and there we go it prints out tim
now notice i'm not just lying to you
here if i type joe
it prints out joe so we are grabbing and
storing the user's name
by using this input tag now the next
thing i actually want to grab from the
user is their age
we're going to do a cool thing here that
make sure they're a certain age before
we let them play the game so let's say
age equals input and then what do you
guys think we should put inside of here
well have a think about it for a second
because i am about to start typing pause
if you need to but i'm going to put what
is
your age and now what's going to happen
is we're going to ask the user for their
name
then we're going to ask the user for
their age and they're going to type both
of those values in so let's run this and
let's say what is your name
tim what is your age 19. boom stops
there we go
now age will store 19 and name will
store
tim so if i want to show you those two
things what i can do is actually print
them out and i'm going to show you
the last thing kind of for this video is
how we print out
multiple things on the same line so
let's say i wanted to say something like
hello tim
you are 19 right so i want to print
their name and then i want to print
their age and i want to combine that
with a few other words just to kind of
welcome the user
well how do i do that there's a few
different ways to do it but the way that
i'm going to show you is kind of the
most common
and it's something like this essentially
you can separate
anything that you want to print on the
same line with a bunch of commas
so i can do something like hello comma
name
and what this will do is print out the
string hello that we've already talked
about we understand we can print out
this and we'll show the text
then we'll print out whatever the
variable name is so whatever's stored
inside of there
and this comma will automatically put a
space in between them
so hello space name where name will be
equal to whatever we typed in
then i can say hello tim
u r and then i'll put age
comma years old
like that and there we go that's all we
need to do to print out hello whatever
their name is
you are whatever their age is years old
so we've just separated
them by commas and now it'll print all
those things out so let's have a look
here
let's go tim 19 hello tim you are 19
years old
and let's say um actually let's just
leave it like that for now
i got rid of some of the comments i had
below and we've just left this now
and what this program does at this point
is just welcomes us to the game
asks us for our name and age and then
prints out the name and age of
the user so whoever typed that in now
what i want to do here and there's a few
things we're going to have to learn to
be able to do this is
check if the user is old enough to play
our game so i want to check if they are
you know
older than 18 or if maybe this game is
pg-13 or something right
that's what i want to make sure that
they're the correct age before we
actually prompt them you know do you
want to play so before we let them start
playing
we want to check that they're older than
a certain age so how do we actually do
that
well that leads me to an important thing
called conditions
so first we need to talk a little bit
about arithmetic so arithmetic is just
math there's four main operators
in or not four sorry there's actually
more than four there are some main
operators inside of python that allow us
to do arithmetic arithmetic is just math
right so we have the asterisk the star
the plus
the minus and the modulus now there's
also a double slash 2 which we'll talk
about
very briefly and these are important
these are the operators
for math operations so the asterisk is
multiplication
the slash the forward slash is division
the plus is addition obviously
the minus is subtraction the percent
sign is actually modulus which gets us
the remainder of a division i'll show
you and the double slash stands for
integer division
so these are the main operators that we
can use and i just want to show you how
we can do some basic math
and just so you have that skill if you
need to use it we may
not use it in this kind of project but
it is something important so i figured
i'd show it
so let's say we have a variable x equals
9 and y equals 8.
what do i do if i want to add x and y
well i could do x plus y
right that technically would add them
but i want to store
that addition somewhere else so just
something important to understand is
that
when you do something like x plus y this
does not
assign x to 17. it might make sense
right if you say oh x
plus y you might be saying like oh add y
to x
i could understand why that may seem
logical to some people
but this doesn't really work in
programming when i do this all that
happens is this gives me a value 17 but
it doesn't get stored anywhere
so what i need to do if i wanted to say
add the value y to the variable x is do
something like
x equals x plus y now i'm going to say
the variable x is equal to whatever the
previous value of x was plus y
that will actually do that addition for
me now same thing
if i do this so plus equals is a
shortcut for what i just showed you
the people that made python know that a
common operation is to add one variable
to another
so rather than having to rewrite you
know x equals x
plus y you can just do x plus equals y
which stands for x is equal to the
addition of
x plus y right that's pretty much what
that's doing so that will assign the
value
of 17 to x if you did something like
that now when you're doing arithmetic
the order of operations apply so let's
say i have a variable z and i said z
is equal to 9 times or not 9 times 8.
x asterisk y plus y
well the order of operations that we
know uh will follow which means this
multiplication will happen
before this addition now let's say we
didn't want that
and we wanted to you know change the
order of operations well
we could use parentheses like we would
in any other map
or any other programming language or
math or whatever and then this will
follow so we will do
the parentheses first now these are the
common operations right so this is
multiplication
that's division uh now i'll just show
you the kind of two or three ones that
you might not know
so the exponential operator which i
actually haven't shown it is the two
asterisks so when you do
two asterisks that stands for raised to
the power so x
raised to the power of y plus y so
whatever that would be
so 16 i guess and then the other two
operators i wanted to show you
were the mod operator and the integer
division operator
so the mod operator what this does is
get the remainder after division so if i
say x mod y
this is actually equal to 1. now the
reason this is equal to one
is because the way you do this is you
say okay how many times does eight
go into uh nine how many times it goes
in one time
fully right it goes in one full time
what is the remainder
what after you take that eight out of
the nine well it's one right so if you
do nine divided by eight
you get one point something but really
it's one remainder one
that's the way you can think of it so
like if i had say five
and two then the mod again would be one
because you say
how many times does two go into five
well it goes in two times okay so what
is that that's four let's take four out
of five
okay what's the remainder now well
there's one left so that's remainder one
it's pretty straightforward that's how
that works whenever you do something
mod 1 obviously the remainder is going
to be 0 because 5 can be
divided by 1 perfectly fine and if i did
something like 0 mod 1
then that would be equal to 0 because 0
does not go into 1 at all so what's the
remainder
0. i hope that makes sense that's the
mod operator for you it's not super
important so i won't spend too much time
on it and then we have
the integer division so integer division
is two slashes
and this is kind of the opposite of mod
it doesn't give you the remainder after
division it gives you the whole number
um division or the whole number quotient
i think is what it's called
so if i do 5 divided by 2 how many times
does 2
evenly go into 5 well it goes in twice
so
the integer division of x by y is going
to be 2
right and then if i change this to 7
same thing so how many times does 2 go
into 7
well it goes in 3 times so the integer
division would be 3.
that is the basics of those mathematical
operators just in case you need to use
them i felt they are important to show
now with those operators there's also a
bunch of other operators too we have a
less than
we have a greater than we have a less
than or equal to a greater than or equal
to
and is equal to and then not equal to
now these are what are known as our
comparison operators and this is how we
actually check
equality between different things you
know you might imagine that it's
actually pretty important for us to
for example check if someone is older
than a certain age
so if we wanted to check if the person's
age was older than 14
we would have to use one of these
operators to do that now this is where
we start talking about
booleans i'm trying not to go too fast
here but again i really do want to get
to the project but some of these things
are pretty fundamental to go through
so actually can i type in here let me
just see if this works ah perfect so
i'll actually do some stuff in the
console for us
and don't worry i'll zoom in quite a bit
so you guys can see this alright so
zoom zoom zoom okay and now i'm just
going to do a few examples of what we
call
conditions or boolean expressions so
remember i showed you that type before
that was bool
right that doesn't matter that you see
that but it was a bool and those were
the values true
or false right so when we use these
conditional operators so that greater
than that less than the less than or
equal to
the greater than or equal to the is
equal to the not equal to
when we use those whatever we put on the
left-hand side and the right-hand side
will be compared using that operator and
we'll either get a true or
false value so if i said something and
this is like a really common example
3 is less than 4. well what do you think
right if i tell you this is going to be
either true or false so it's going to be
one of those boolean types what do you
think this would be
well of course that's true because 3 is
indeed less than four right
and then if i swatch uh switch this
around i say three
greater than four well we get false
because three is not greater than four
so this is the basics on how these
conditional operators work
and i can do something like you know 45
less than or equal to 45. now is this
true or false
well that's true because the way that
this works is it checks if the value on
the left-hand side
is less than or equal to this value
right and that's kind of the basics on
how some of these things work now let me
see can i clear there we go awesome
let's hit enter here and see if we can
start typing now the important ones that
we want to go through though
are comparing for equality that's
something we want to do a lot of time so
comparing numbers using the less than
and greater than signs
that's pretty easy i think that makes
sense to most of you you know it's
either true or false you can read it and
pretty well figure it out
but sometimes uh when we have checking
for equality it can be a little bit
different
so if i have something like five equals
equals 5 what this is
what this says is is 5 equal to 5. so
what i did before right when we made a
variable we could do something like x
equals 5.
and that is an assignment that means
we're assigning 5 to the value x
but if i go x equals equals five
what i'm asking is is like is x
equal to five the two equal sign is like
a question mark almost like is this true
give me the result
whereas the one equal sign is an
assignment you're telling x that yes
it is equal to 5. so if i say x equals
equals 5
we get the value true right and in fact
what i can do is make a variable called
y
let's say y equals 5 and i could say x
equals equals y
and we'll get true all that happens when
i use the variables here
is it will just check what their value
is so we've assigned their values here
and it will compare their values and
tell me if that's true or false
so that is the very basics of how we can
use that equality so equals equals
and then there's one more which is the
not equals to
and what this does is tell us if two
values are not the same
so whatever the result of the two equal
sign would be it's just
reverse so in this case x is equal to y
so since they're not
equal to each other or since they are
equal to each other the not equal to
will give us false right so if we look
at false it says no
these actually are equal to each other
so we're getting false for the not equal
to operator
i hope that makes sense now lastly we
can compare
strings right so i can do something like
hello equals equals
hello and boom that works fine that's
totally true
but what happens if i try to do this
hello equals five
no we cannot assign oh sorry not hello
equals five hello equals equals five
what am i saying
we get the value false right so we can
when we compare different types like an
int
and a string together obviously those
aren't going to be the same and what if
i actually go ahead and do something
like this
5 equals equals 5. well that's false 2.
so even though
these values are technically the same
since this is a string
and this is an int we're going to get
false so that's very important that when
we're checking things they are the same
type because if they're not then we're
going to get errors like this where they
might actually be the same value
but it's not showing up as the same
value so i'm hoping this is making sense
of course we're going to go through more
examples
but last thing i'll show you is that
when i do like hello equals
equals hello do we think this is going
to be equal or not
if you have a look at it yes no what do
you think let's run this
we get false so whenever there's any
capital letters that really matters so
just make sure you understand that
the types really matter and the
capitalization matters as well
and i'm going to show you ways that we
can deal with that because you could
imagine like if we're checking
to see if the user types something in we
want them if they type it in with a
capital letter or not with a capital
letter we still want that to work right
we still want to check
and see that that value is uh is what we
want it to be equal to
so anyways that was kind of the theory
that we needed to go through now let's
get it into the project and start
working on it apologize if that was
longer than uh
than anticipated all right so what did i
want to do
i wanted to check if the user's age was
over a certain value
so what i need to do is i need to write
an expression that pretty much checks if
age is greater than you know some some
value right
so let's first of all check this let's
print
and we're actually going to go and we're
going to say is underscore older so i'm
going to get a variable called
is older i'm going to set that equal to
age and we'll say age
greater or equal to 18. so what this is
going to do
is it's going to assign whatever the
value of this expression is so this will
either be true or false
to the variable is older and then i'll
print
is underscore older just like that so
this will just tell us true or false
and let's actually have a look at what
we get here because it might surprise
you a bit
so let's run this and let's have a look
at what we get so let's go name
tim age 19 and we get a bunch of red
text this is our first red text that
we've seen
so this is an error message i did this
purposely and i want us to read what
actually happened here
and see what line it happened at so that
we understand what happens when we get
an error message so if you see this red
text
don't worry it just means you've done
something wrong you know
could be well it definitely is your
fault because you typed it but
you can definitely figure out what's
wrong just by reading through this error
message quite easily so you can see it
says traceback most recent call
last you know don't worry about this
gibberish if it doesn't make sense
that's fine what you're really looking
for here is the line number
the actual line where the thing went
wrong and then what the error was so in
this case it says file main.pi so that's
the file we're working in
line seven okay so line seven this is
the expression so is older equals age
greater than or equal to eighteen
and then type error greater than or
equal to is not supported between
instance of string and int
so what that actually means is that this
age variable here
is a string and this here on the right
hand side
is an int so i cannot compare if the
string like because imagine if i had a
string like you know hello
i can't say hello greater than or equal
to 18. that doesn't make any sense i
can't do that
and since age is a string we can't do
that but what it why is age a string
didn't i type in 19
that's weird well by default whenever
you type something in
using input it automatically comes in as
a string
so even though i typed in 19 like this
and i didn't put the two quotation marks
around it
it automatically looks like this inside
of my program
that's just the way it works because
this input doesn't know what we're going
to type right
so it has to just assume it's going to
be a string because a string can hold
anything inside of it so long as it's
wrapped in the quotation marks
so that's why we have to do that so
anyways that's what we do
and yeah so we now need to actually find
a way that we can convert this
age to an integer so we need to take
that string value
and we need to convert it to an int so
that we can actually compare these two
things
so the way that i do that is i write int
and then i
wrap the variable age with this in so i
say int open bracket close bracket
around
h now that says whatever this age is is
so whatever number this age is because
in this case it's a string that's 19.
let's just strip out the number from
that so get rid of the quotation marks
and make this an int value
so now if i say is older equals the int
value of whatever the age is so take
those quotation marks away just make it
an integer
and check if that's greater than or
equal to 18. so that's
this will work now so let's actually
have a look at this so what is your name
tim
what's your age 19 hello tim you are 19
years old and then it says true
so that totally worked and that was fine
we were able to convert
the string that we typed in into a
number so just keep that in mind if
you're asking a user to type in a number
then you want to make sure you convert
whatever they typed into an integer
so that when you want to compare it or
you want to use it it's actually an
integer value
and there's another way to do this i can
type int around the input statement up
here
and the reason this works is because
this is pretty much doing the exact same
thing we're doing down here
except now we're going to actually
assign an integer value
to the age variable rather than just
convert the age variable later on to an
end
so it takes the input whatever the user
types in and then immediately just
converts it right into an integer
and now i can remove this and this will
still work because this is being
converted to an integer immediately so
let's run this
let's say what is your name tim what is
your age 19
and now we get hello to him you're 19
years old true all right so we've
covered a lot
of stuff there's one more thing to go
through and this will be kind of the
most exciting thing we do so far
so i'm excited to do it and this is
called the if statement so right now we
just printed true but ideally you know i
want to give the user some different
messages based on if they're old enough
or not right i don't want to just print
out true
so how do i do that well this is where
we use the if statement
so you've seen that we make these little
conditions right by using these
conditional operators and these are
either true or false
now the reason we use these is because
we can use them inside of an if
statement
so actually what i can do is i don't
need brackets but i'm going to
remove this variable is older and i'm
going to take this age greater than 18.
i'm just going to kind of code something
out and then i'll talk about how this
works
if we could get this typing right you
are old enough
okay so what this is saying
is this is an if statement what the if
statement does it says
if the condition here is true
do this that's as simple as it is you
literally read it like plain english you
write the keyword if so if
you write some condition here whatever
you want to check
but this needs to compare or it needs to
be true or false so this needs to
evaluate to true or false
and then you put a colon it's important
you add the colon
then down here you do a tab right so you
tab in so one indent level
and whatever is inside of this indented
block underneath the if statement will
happen
if this condition is true if it's not
true it will simply skip whatever is
indented
and just keep moving on in the program
so i'll just show you because i'm going
to print this twice
just so that this makes sense so i'll
print this two times so now
if the age is greater than or equal to
18 we'll print you're old enough twice
so let's run this
and let's go ahead was your name tim was
your age
19 hello tim you're 19 years old you are
old enough you are old enough so that is
exactly how that works
now there's one more component to show
to this and i think that was easy enough
hopefully that makes sense it's just if
you write some condition here and then
if that condition is true
you go ahead and you do whatever is in
this block now what about
if they're not older than 18 right so if
i run this again and i say what is your
name
tim 19 hello tim you're an uh well i
should
i should have selected an age that was
younger let's do tim 17
hello tim you're 17 years old what if i
want to tell them that they're not old
enough to play
well i could do another if statement
right i could do if age
is less than 18 and then i could print
that out but there's actually an easier
way to do this
and this is using an else so this else
statement
kind of combines with the if and
whenever you write an if you have the
option you don't have to but it's up to
you if you want
to put an else statement afterwards that
tells you
what to do if this condition is not true
so essentially this is saying if this is
true
do this otherwise do this and now we're
going to put another indented statement
and we're going to say you are
not old enough
to play dot dot so let's try this now
and just see how this works so let's go
tim let's go 17 and now it says hello
tim you're
17 years old you are not old enough to
play whereas before it told us we were
old enough to play
so that is the basics of the if
statement so we have the if and the else
now i'll show you one more thing with
the if statement and then we'll kind of
start the very beginning of our game and
then continue the rest of it in the next
one
but we've almost learned pretty much
everything we need to know
so now we're going to go else
if so ellis if is another statement that
we can use and the way that this works
is essentially we're
checking for one more thing so let's say
we had three options right
maybe if they were younger than 14 um
they just couldn't play
if they were older than 14 but they had
a parent with them they're allowed to
play and if they're older than 19 they
could play along
maybe those are the three options we
have so what i could actually do is i
could change this around a bit and i can
say if age is greater than or equal to
18 you're old enough to play
then i could say else if so if this
isn't true
but this is true so what i put here age
is greater than or equal to 14
then what i can do is print
you can play with supervision or
something
supervision okay so now what i'm saying
is uh what is this sorry
not elsif this should be el if i'm
coding another language here sorry not
else if
l if e l i f apologize about that but l
if then you put the condition and then
whatever you put in the indented block
below that will happen
if this is not true but this is true so
i hope that makes sense but it goes like
you know
check this if it's true do this and skip
the rest of it
and then if this is not true check this
if this is true
do this skip the rest of it if this is
not true
go into the else and do this that is
kind of the way that this works and you
can actually
put multiple l if statements underneath
each other so you can do if l if l if l
if l if else
and these again are all optional but
just remember that the else always comes
at the end
the lfs go in between and that you can
have as many of them as you want but you
don't need to so that's an important
thing but let's just have a look at what
happens now
and say what is your name tim what is
your age let's do
15 and now it says hello tim you're 15
years old you can play with supervision
so that is the basics of the if elif
else now let me scrap this
actually i won't scrap this but i'll get
rid of the else if and let's leave it at
this for now because it's going to say
okay
actually we'll add one more thing to
finish it up if age is greater than or
equal to 18
print you are old enough to play
and now what i want to do to wrap this
up is ask them a question
do you want to play so if they're old
enough to play let's ask them if they
want to play
and let's do that inside of here so only
if they're older than 18 and they're old
enough to play
then i will ask them if they want to
play otherwise i'm not going to so
inside this if statement i'm actually
going to say
you know wants underscore to
underscore play you can name this
variable anything you want i just like
to make mine descriptive
and i'll say input do you
want oops do you want
to play now i'm doing a space here just
so that when they start typing and i
forgot to mention this in the last video
when they start typing it doesn't get
squished right beside the text so i just
add a space afterwards
and it makes it a little bit nicer but
wants to play equals input do you want
to play
and now i'm going to check if they want
to play so i'm going to say if
and i'll actually say wants to play
equals equals
yes so if what they type in is equal to
yes
then print
let's play exclamation point
so i know that was a lot let me zoom out
a bit here just so we can read this a
little bit easier
and now let's run this program for the
last time before we wrap up this video
so what is your name
tim what is your age 18.
hello tim you're 18 years old you're old
enough to play do you want to play
let's type yes and it says let's play
awesome let's run this one more time
what is your name
tim what is your age let's go younger
than this time so let's go 17.
hello tim you're 17 years old you're not
old enough to play
so i hope this is starting to make sense
but i'll just give you a really quick
summary
so we welcome the user we ask them for
their name and their age
we convert their age right away to a
number so that we can actually compare
it later on
we then say hello whatever their name is
you are whatever their age is years old
we then check how old they are if
they're older than 18 we tell them
they're old enough to play
and then we ask them if they want to
play if they say yes so if they type in
the string yes
we print let's play otherwise we tell
them they're not old enough to play
and that is the very beginning of our
game and i hope you can see what's going
to happen here in the future right
so when they want to play now what i'm
going to do is inside of here i'm going
to ask them their first question
so i'm going to say okay you know your
first decision is do you want to go left
or right or we'll make something up
and we're going to keep kind of chaining
inwards and nesting if statements
together
just to make all these blocks with all
these different decisions
and you're going to see it's going to
get pretty intricate pretty quickly but
i think this is pretty cool
and right now you've learned almost
everything you need to know to make this
full game
so the first thing i'm going to do is
just kind of recap and just kind of run
this program and see what we actually
have so far so we know where we're going
from here
so welcome to my first game what is your
name my name is tim what is your age
19. hello tim you are 19 years old
you're old enough to play
do you want to play let's type yes
like that and boom it says let's play
awesome now i just want to show you a
case that we may not have considered yet
so if i do tim
19 and do you want to play now what
happens if i do something like this so y
capital e s well i'll give you guys an
opportunity to take a look at it if we
have our condition here right so we say
wants to play equals input do you want
to play
and we say if wants to play equals yes
let's play
so do we think when i type y with a
capital e and then
s that this is going to work well no
it's not so if i do this
it actually doesn't this if statement is
not true this condition is not true and
therefore this doesn't run
so how can i actually go about and fix
that well
this is the first thing that i wanted to
show you and that i guarantee you guys
will find very useful for the rest of
this kind of game and anything in the
future
there is this method and it's called a
method that's it's not that important
you don't have to understand what that
means
uh called dot lower so it actually looks
like this dot lower and i'm typing it in
the correct place here
but what this does is it takes any
string and immediately converts it into
lower cases
so all lower cases it takes any letters
it has and just put it
puts it to lowercase so this is really
useful because what we can do
is we can take the input that we typed
in immediately convert it all into
lowercases
and now when we want to check for
equality it doesn't matter
what capitalization we used in the
string it will still
be true because it'll just automatically
go to lower case so we could type
capital e
and that will still this condition will
be true and we'll still do let's play
so in fact let me show you so notice i
just put dot lower here
and guess what there's actually another
method called dot
upper that we could use as well and dot
upper will make it all uppercase so if
we wanted to do this
and make this all uppercase and then
make this
dot upper same thing right so i'm hoping
this is making sense but
essentially whatever you're going to
compare here is going to have to be in
all lowercase or all upper case
and that's going to correspond to
whether you use lower or dot upper
all right so let's run this now and
let's see what we get
so what is your name tim what is your
age 19 do you want to play
y e s okay so we have a capital y and a
capital s
and let's play that still works fine so
that's cool
i think that's an important method to
know that's pretty quick so i just
wanted to show that to you guys
and now let's actually start building a
game let's start making something cool
and then we'll implement
like maybe a health or some other
interesting things into our game that i
didn't have in the demo game
so the first thing we want to do is
actually i'm going to add an else
statement here and i'm just going to
print
sia dot dot so if they don't want to
play we'll simply tell them you know
goodbye like see you later
and then inside of here if they want to
play so notice i'm
nesting all these things right like
there's an if and else inside of another
if statement
and that's totally fine because all the
if statement says as well
if this is true do whatever is indented
and
here we are and then inside here this if
statement says if this is true
do whatever's indented right so we go
ahead and do that so what i'm going to
do in here now
is i'm going to ask another question and
this will be the first decision that we
want to make so i don't know what i want
to make it i think i'm going to go with
the classic do you want to go left or
right
just as our first kind of path but you
guys can make this whatever you want and
feel free at this point to kind of
change around some of the stuff that i'm
doing
and make it your own so long as you
understand what's happening so i'm going
to say left underscore or
underscore right equals input
first choice dot dot dot
left or right now it might be a good
idea in your game
to put brackets at the end of your
answer and just put inside of the
brackets what the user
should type so left or right because
technically right they might not know
like they might type i want to go left
or i want to go right
so it might be a good idea to just put
brackets inside of the prompt just so
they kind of know
what options they have like what they
can actually type right
and then what i'm going to do after this
is i'm going to check if
left underscore or underscore right
is equal to left this will be my correct
decision if i go
left then what we'll do is we'll print
something or we'll do something
otherwise we'll we'll just print out to
the screen
you fell down and
lost dot dot you can see i'm not super
creative when it comes to making these
games but the idea is i'm just trying to
show you how the paths work
um so this is like if they lose so if
they decide to go right or they type
anything other than
left then we'll print out you fell down
and lost
otherwise if they go left then what i'll
ask them is another question so say okay
if they go left
they're going the right direction so
let's ask them another question
awesome and in fact inside of else i
don't even have to make them lose i
could ask them another question in here
too right
we can make it as confusing as
complicated as we want and make it
really hard for the user to figure out
what way they're kind of going so they
have to play the game a bunch of times
so anyways let's go here inside of left
and let's say
i'm just going to put ans that's short
form for answer that's what i usually
end up doing as we get longer and longer
rather than making these variable names
but i'm going to say
ans equals input
nice you follow the path
and reach a
lake do you swim
across or go around
question mark and then inside of here
i'm going to put a cross
as the answer right is that a cross i
don't think you need two c's so across
or around just telling them what they
can type in right
and now i'm gonna have to zoom out a
little bit just so we can read oh that's
better okay
and now inside of here what i'm gonna do
is i'm gonna check what their answer was
right so i'm going to say if
ans is equal to and maybe we'll say that
going across was the correct answer
actually let's say going around was the
correct answer so if a and s equals a
round
then we'll do something and then we'll
say l if so i'm actually going to switch
it up here
just to show you something else l if um
lf ns equals equals
across and then else
so the reason i've done this is because
what i actually want to do
right now is i want to make it so that
if they type across or they type around
both options are correct they can go
both way but both ways will lead them to
different types of decisions right so
we'll get asked now different questions
inside of here
but if they don't type around or across
right then i want them to lose so i'm
just going to go down here and say print
you lost again i don't have really good
like you know lose messages but that's
totally fine
and then inside of here in round what
i'm actually going to say is that one of
these options is better than the other
so here is where i'm going to implement
something that i hope is you guys will
appreciate because it is a little bit
more complicated but i want to show you
how we can do something like this
if they decide to go across the lake i'm
gonna
kind of make up a story and say they got
bit by something and they lose health
and maybe we'll put something inside of
here that checks you know what their
health is so if their health goes lower
than zero
then they lose right then they lose the
game completely i think that'll be
interesting to do so let's do something
like that
so if i want to keep track of health
right and maybe we set them off with
like default health of one or default
health of 10 or something
and they lose health we'll need a
variable to store their health and then
we'll need to subtract from that
variable
so what i'm going to do is on line 7 i'm
going to make a variable called health
i'm going to set that equal to 10. so
they could technically have 10 health
and we'll tell them how much health they
start with and how much health they lose
so maybe to start we'll print out
you are starting with
and then in this case comma
the number and then comma health so you
are starting with 10 health that'll
print out 10.
the reason i put health here instead of
10 is because if i change this number
maybe i change it later to 15 20
something like that i want this to
automatically update
i don't want to have to rewrite the
number two times it's better just to
have it stored in one place so that's
why i've done that
so we've defined they have a health and
we'll say if a and s
equals a round um then you know whatever
if a and s equals a cross
then we'll print something else in fact
actually what we can do is something
cool here and i'm going to get rid of
the else and just
just change this a bit so i'm going to
say print
and inside of here i'm going to put you
went around and reached
the other side
of the lake and then here i'll print
you managed to get
across but were bit
by a fish i don't know let's just say
that you were bit by a fish
and lost five health
so i'm gonna tell them that they lost
five health here and then what i'm gonna
do is because they lost health and i'll
put some periods here
is i will say health minus equals five
so we'll just you know remove five
health from their health so now they
only have five health
and now what we can do down here is we
can ask them another question right and
we can keep going and in fact
what i'll do now is i'll pause and we'll
run this just to see where we're at
right now
and then i'll just kind of keep going
and just coding out my version of the
game just showing you guys some
different cool things that we can do
and hopefully you guys take this upon
yourself to make your own cool game
right and change the paths and decisions
and this will be like really good
template for you to figure out what to
do so let's run this
and let's go what is your name so my
name is tim i'm 19. hello tim you're 19
years old you're starting with 10 health
you're old enough to play do you want to
play so actually maybe i should put the
hell somewhere else this is great so i
tested i realized something was wrong
so now i only want to tell them how much
help they have right
if they're older than 18. so in fact
let's get rid of this
you know telling them what they are i
don't need that anymore and then after
we ask them do you want to play
we'll print out you're starting with 10
health let's play and we can leave the
health defined up here
it doesn't matter where we have it but
we'll just put it here so that we can
access it throughout
all of the stuff down here great so
let's run this now
and let's zoom in a bit says what is
your name tim
what is your age 19 uh you're old enough
to play do you want to play
yes you're starting with 10 health let's
play first choice left or right so where
should we go let's go left
nice you follow the path and reach a
lake do you want to swim across or go
around
let's go across and it says you managed
to get across but you were bit by fish
and lost five health
so you can see that the game is actually
working right and we'll run it one more
time just to
test out another path so tim 19 you're
old enough to play do you want to play
yes first choice left or right let's go
right
you fell down and lost boom so the game
is functioning okay so let's keep going
and let's add some more stuff into this
so health minus equals five so now we're
at five health
now what i'm going to do here is we'll
have to do something to check
if they are lower than zero health right
so they'll be at some point where
they could potentially lose all their
health and if they're at lower than zero
health or they're at zero health then
we'll have to tell them
that they lost so that's going to be
interesting to do actually
but first let's just ask another
question so let's say ans
equals input and inside here what do we
want them to do next
maybe i'll tell them that i'm going to
take an example from my previous game
i'll say you see a river and you see a
house do you go towards the river or do
you follow the house right
or other way around you go towards the
house or do you follow the river okay
you notice a house
and a river which do you go to
and then again i'll give them what they
need to type in here just to make it
easy so we'll say river
slash house and make sure we add a space
here in between the question mark
and the end of the quote just so there's
a a space when they're actually typing
it in
and now let's check if ans equals
equals in this case house
then we'll do something else we'll do
something else
so what i'm actually going to say here
this will be kind of an interesting
little twist to this game i wasn't even
thinking about adding
is if they decide to go to the river
we'll just tell them that they like fell
in the river and they lost okay
and then if they go towards the house
we'll tell them that they went towards
the house but they
lost five health because like the guy at
the house hit them or something i don't
know i'm trying not to be too uh
too violent in these answers but the
idea being that
i wanted to make i want to make it so
that they can get past this but if they
decide to
go across it will actually end up being
the wrong decision because
they lose five health right and then
down here they'll lose another five
so they'll lose the game i hope that
makes sense but you'll see as i start
coding it
so if ans equals house then what we'll
say is we'll say print
you end you go to the house
go to the house and
are greeted oops by
the owner dot dot dot he
doesn't like you and you
lose five help why not
all right we'll just go with that we
don't need any more deeper explanations
then we'll say health
minus equals five so we're removing five
health again that's equivalent to health
equals
health minus five so whatever the value
of health is we'll subtract five from it
the reason i wouldn't just set health to
five or i wouldn't just set it to 0 is
because
we don't know if they lost 5 health
above here so we need to make sure we
just subtract that value
and then else we'll print down here
you fell in the river
and lost dot dot dot okay so now
what we'll do after this right so you
can kind of see the way that i'm
ah actually let's see here managed to
get across so now actually inside of
this
if statement sorry i'm just trying to
think of what we're actually going to do
here on line 30
i'm going to check if their health is
lower than zero so if they have lower
than zero health because this will be
the first point in the game
where they could potentially be at zero
health if they lost it twice
then we'll tell them that they lost
otherwise we'll keep going right and
then maybe we'll wrap up the game with
one more path or something
so we'll say if health is less than or
equal to zero
then what we'll do is we'll print
you now have
zero health and we don't need a comma
and you
lose the game dot dot dot
all right so there we go you lost the
game actually we'll just do and you
lost the game all right so if their
health is lower than zero they lose
otherwise then inside of here we'll say
print
you have
survived you win i don't know we'll just
say that they win at that point and i'll
show you how we can add some more cool
things too
all right so that pretty much wraps it
up let's test this game a few times and
make sure that everything's working
fine uh and then we'll add anything we
need to so what is your name
tim let's actually test one if i go like
14 uh you're not allowed to play okay so
let's go again
tim 19 yes
first choice left or right let's go left
nice you follow the path and reach a leg
do you swim across you go around
let's go across you managed to get
across
but you were bit by a fish and lost five
health you notice a house and a river
which you go to the river the house
let's go to the river
and you fell in the river and lost okay
let's try a few more paths
just want to make sure this works but i
hope you guys understand the point of
this right is to go down like all these
different branching paths and
you know if you make a bad decision at
the beginning you're going to have to
keep going down all the roots until you
realize that oh no i should have gone
right instead of left right
so you can make these really intricate
and a lot of people that i've taught to
do this before
have made really cool games they're like
hundreds of lines of code that take you
a really long time to actually figure
out so i think it's pretty interesting
okay but first choice left or right
let's go left
nice you follow the path and reach a
lake do you swim across or go around
let's actually go across and let's test
out this health stuff so we go across
and then says you know it's a house and
a river so let's go to the house it says
you go to the house and you are greeted
oops i should probably spell that right
by the owner he doesn't like you and you
lose five health
you know you now have zero health and
you lost the game right so you didn't
technically lose because you went to the
um what is it because you went to the
house it just you lost because you lost
five health right now i'll show you the
example
where if we don't lose five health at
the first step
we can actually survive by going to the
house so what is your name tim
what is your age 19 do you want to play
yes let's play first choice left or
right so let's go left
let's say nice you follow let's go
around this time
you went around and reached the other
side of the lake you know what's the
house in the river which you go to let's
go to the house
and you go to health and you're greeted
by the owner he doesn't like you and you
lose five health you have survived you
win
so even though we lost five health we
still won because in the previous step
we didn't lose five health
so i hope that me showing you the health
thing gave you some ideas for some stuff
that you can do
what you also can do is you can ask you
can do something like let the user pick
a weapon or something right
so a cool example and i'll just talk
about some kind of add-ons now because
we're kind of wrapping up the video
anyways
you could do something like you can
start by asking them what weapon you
want so you could say you know
weapon equals input
pick a weapon question mark or pick a
weapon colon and then your options could
be something like
sword um i don't know maybe like a baton
i'm trying not to be too violent and i
don't know let's go something like taser
right so you could tell them to pick
one of these weapons and then based on
the weapon they pick you can say oh well
if they have this weapon
then they're able to get past this
obstacle if they don't have this weapon
then they can't so what you would do
if you wanted to check something like
that is you'd say if
weapon equals equals whatever it equals
and if it equals that
then boom they're good to go right and
they can continue on now the last thing
i'll show you because we have one minute
left
kind of before i'm planning on wrapping
this up is how you can actually check
multiple things on the same line now i'm
just going to kind of introduce this to
you guys because then you can kind of
look at it yourself it's pretty easy
there's these things called and and or
now and and or are ways that we can
chain conditions together
i'm not going to explain them in depth
but if you do something like true
or false the result of this
is true the reason this is true is
because when you have an
or this pretty much says look at the
left side
look at the right side if one of them
are true the whole thing is true
so if you go ahead and do something like
you know
x let's i don't know i say like
5 equals 5
7 equals equals 8 then this would be
true right because this condition is
true
this condition is false so since one of
them is true the whole thing is true
now contrasting that with and so when
you do and what this does
is it checks if both of the things on
the left and right hand side
are true if they are the whole thing is
true if they're not it's false so in
this case this will be false because one
of them is false
but if i change this to be like 7 equals
equals 7 then
this is true so you can use this and
and or to actually chain conditions
together so you could check
like inside of here if left or right and
you know weapon equals equals whatever
you can do something like that oops so i
put this in the wrong
uh if left left or right equals equals
left oops
and weapon equals equals whatever it
equals right inside of here
then this whole thing will work so you
can check if this whole condition
is true or false and then execute an if
statement based on that
so with that being said i think that's
pretty much it i'm going to zoom out
here
so you guys can have a look at all of
the code at once i understand this maybe
isn't mobile friendly but at least now
you can kind of see
what we've actually created and i really
hope that throughout this series you
guys have learned something about python
you've learned kind of the basics of the
language and if and else and i've given
you enough knowledge that you now feel a
little bit confident to go out there
and make some kind of cool game i will
say there's a ton more stuff
you can do with this there's a lot more
things to learn but again the focus of
this series was around building a
project and i really hope that this
helped you do that
so that being said that has been it i
hope you guys enjoyed if you did make
sure you leave a like
subscribe and i will see you in another
youtube video